for the mothers of gods of the daily
struggle is especially tough
to raise children to keep them safe in a
place that is notoriously dangerous and
to keep them fed
a mother of four relies in overseas help
to put food on the table that help is
being withdrawn
I definitely think of how to
you can see they are children and they
don't understand the reasons of the lack
of food we can't survive without it
close to 2 million Palestinian
independent food Aid years of
instability and the rising cost of
living increase the threat of more
people going hungry it agencies rely on
donor funding and for Gaza funding has
been drying up right now there is
enormous pressure globally on Aid
budgets and Aid allocations it's
certainly the case here in Gaza
we share the food caseload the food
program work with world food program
they have already announced that they
are cutting back their programming the
world footer program shutting down here
next month other young agencies are also
cutting back
in Gaza alone around 400 000 people
could lose vital Food Supplies
threatening a human tearing crisis we
took about a hundred thousand families
in Gaza in need of food support and the
cut has reached approximately 20 000
families however we are waiting for the
approval of more names in the future
children going hungry is already a
reality the people of Gaza possessed
against all the odds surviving on the
bare minimum food Aida provided this
essential Lifeline however is now on the
train